check your watches it's 8 44 what time
is it time for cbs morning seals this
week we have four products designed with
wellness in mind available at exclusive
prices just for you
and they might just become essentials in
your everyday life to start shopping now
scan the qr code it's right there on
your screen scan
you could there it goes you can also
visit cbsdeals.com
lifestyle host with a great name gail
bass
joins us now with more gail with a shot
of you that we took in the green room
looked like you were having a moment i
was having a relaxing i wasn't sure what
she was doing in there yeah you could
have all kinds of moments with these
things what people are without let's
start with with people who are without
hey well let's remember that this is
product tested by walter the wonder dog
this is the call we learned about your
walter last time yeah well walter tested
this out because when i first got this
over a year ago there you could see him
right there with the controller in his
hand this thing's has multiple settings
it has heat and vibration and everybody
can use this this is something that you
could throw over your shoulder
well it's one it's it's kind of like a
hot pad but this hot pad vibrates so you
said you wanted something for an ankle
if you're doing heat therapy on your
ankle you could pop your ankle on this
you could throw it over your shoulder
in bed on the couch i streamed a lot of
tv like cbs this morning in the morning
when it's cold outside i could curl up
with you guys on this thing and just get
my my sore back
i put it on my sore back so that's
something i really liked and i also
really like the price normally it's
69.99 we have it for 50 off so it's
32.50 this is a fantastic stocking
stuffer not too soon to talk about it
because this is a great gift for
teachers who are on their feet or for
you or for somebody you know who needs a
stocking stuffer okay so this is
stocking this is all about heat and
comfort this is about comfort here but
it's a cooler approach tell them well
this does heat and it can uh and you
could put it in the freezer this is the
air thera ice rx what i love about this
and i'll just show you even with my big
hair i can put this thing on you put it
on for a little self-care like for a
woman of a certain age like myself
and uh your head gets a little hot
because of a flash yeah it is cold it's
been in the freezer
it is so nice still moving move closer
to me i'm over here follow my voice
that feels good
yes it feels good when you have a bird
box like i say when you're having like a
hot flash and you put that i did and i
put it on i was like oh my gosh this is
the relief i'm looking for
and that does heat therapy so you put it
in the microwave a few seconds at a time
just to get it to the warm temperature
that you want and it is great how much
this one is 34.95 normally we have it
for 17.50 this is great for frequent
travelers businessmen or you know mom
needs a moment to herself before the
kids get home from school this is this
is a really cool okay it's called
thermal ice so we have clara ice yeah we
have a couple of products by re-athlete
um and this one is the deep 4s pro what
is this this one is a massage gun if you
take this thing out i'm going to use you
as a model i'm going to turn this on and
re-athlete him okay now
what's feeling you know the shoulder a
little shoulder okay here we go level
one oh hey now you feel that yeah all
right that feel good yeah yeah and
what's great about this thing is you're
on go get my calf
nate you're on tv
that feels good isn't that great this is
a wonderful product if you just want to
target a certain area plus the head is
movable so if you feel like oh my arm's
too short you can reach every part of
your back and i used it for a back
scratcher the other day i'm like well i
got this little thing so that the you
know what's the price
yeah this is a great deal we have this
for
149.50 that's
that's normally 29.99
299.99 that's 150 that's a great price
yeah what about these we saw you with
those in the green yeah that's what you
were wearing yeah that's what i was
gonna explain this is the re-athlete leg
massager it's the air sea it's the air c
pro and what i love about this is after
i tried it i went hiking my legs were a
little stiff like yesterday i walked
around the high line did four miles
around town i wanted to put this on
right and it's an air compression so you
could do it from a low level to a higher
level and my friends who have this use
this for soreness because they're all
triathletes and it's one of those things
that just makes you feel better yeah
i've seen products like this in locker
rooms across the country yes lactic acid
inflammation oh so you know this name oh
for sure not only high quality
not only locker rooms we got it in
another green room shot as well who do
we got jamie uh who's changing into
shorts it would appear uh snagged a
second pair of the re-athlete
how much is this this is a great price
normally
299.99 we have it for
139.99 that is more than 50 off that's
160 savings get your credit card out
jamie wax all right gail bass nicely
done and we know this is walter's
favorite i like it
you saw today scan that qr code on your
screen
nate's just playing around you can also
visit cbsdeals.com we'll be right back
they won't be right back